so let's have a think about this can we
remember back to yesterday seems like a
long time ago now in terms of concepts
do you remember if we gave you a
function that was the sum of a couple of
things or even the sum of a bunch of
things like three or four or five things
then to find the derivative of that
whole function you can just add up each
of the individual derivatives do you
remember that right so if I've got like
say U and V then your result will just
be I can write this in an abbreviated
form you - just differentiate that guy
and then add it to V - which is the
derivative of the other guy right so the
sum sorry the derivative of a sum is the
sum of the druze that's what we that's
one of the things that we showed we even
went and did did with first principles
okay now you guys know it matters all
their patterns right so one of the
things that's that would be nice is if
this is true you differentiate a sum you
get a sum does it stand to reason then
that the derivative of a product this is
what happens we multiply things right
would that would that be the product of
the derivatives so what that might look
like is something like this
differentiate this guy it's you -
differentiate this guy it's V - and then
would it be the case that you just
multiply those two doodoos right now
hopefully the fact that I am posing this
question to you in this way should raise
your alarm bells because this would be
really lovely but reality is often a
little more complicated than we would
like and believe it or not you have all
the information all the knowledge you
need to prove that this is not true so
I'm going to rehearse it for you real
quick
right let's think about a function that
you know let's consider a function like
say 5x that's a function we've met we've
this is simple enough we know how to
differentiate this right what's the
derivative it's just 5 right that's the
gradient function this is just a
straight line the gradients always 5 all
the way along okay but 5x we can also
consider that as a product as something
multiplied by something else right let's
see what happens if we consider the
derivative of each of those individual
parts that are in the product one of
them is 5 and then the other one is X
five times ax can someone tell me you
what's the derivative of five it's ya
know zero zip then you read this guy the
dude if of X that's just well yeah I
will get an answer sec but it doesn't
matter because the first thing I the
front is 0 it does turn out to be 1 by
the way that's DX or DX isn't it of
course it should be 1
it's a faction right so what you get is
this now hopefully you can see this
contradiction here right we know what
the derivative is supposed to be if you
look at each of the components of the
product and differentiate them
individually you do not get I mean you
get something but it's not that it's not
the real answer right so it turns out
this is not the case the derivative of
product
sadly is not the product of the
derivatives it's something a little more
complicated so I'm going to tell you
right now you might want to get your pen
for this part I'm gonna tell you what
the real product rule is it's actually
not that different but it is a little
more complex I should say complicated
complex' means something else in maths
so here's the product rule ok if you are
differentiating a product some function
times some other functions so if I write
this the derivative of one function I'm
just going to call it u multiplied by
some other function I'm gonna call it V
instead of just simply the product of
these two you get this I'm gonna write
it two ways one way that looks a bit
messy and then a way that's going to be
a bit more neater and easier to remember
V du yuan DX + u DV + DX this is a bit
more work to remember isn't it it is so
much more messy than this but sometimes
reality is messy there's a proof for
this but it's a little bit
time-consuming and you can see how
quickly we've been running through
things so if you if you'd like very
happy to run through that proof with you
but the proof doesn't add too much to
your use of this form you can still use
it quite happily without it now I
mentioned before this is like a messy
gross way of writing it there's a
slightly more memorable and concise way
of writing it the derivative of
you using our notation up here we can
just write it as u with a - right so
instead of writing V times this long
walk or doing a derivative instead of
using Leibniz notation I'm just gonna
say V times u - and then how would you
write this spit on the end start with
you what's this thing it's just it's
just V - right so when I got taught this
when I was in year 11 my NASA teacher
called this evolve because that's what
it sounds like right
alright said Ian what I just hit the
what I don't know what you're talking
about yeah I mean I suppose you could
because addition you could reverse the
direction so if you prefer it you could
call it an mu but there are going to be
reasons later on that I'm going to
suggest actually despite the fact that
they're both equivalent in this context
this is actually a better way to
remember in this order okay so can we
quickly look at an example let's just
look at this one first let's look at
this example here right that was the
simple way it doesn't work so can we do
it using this product rule I'm gonna say
that the derivative of 5x is and I'm
gonna encourage you to get another color
out and we're gonna call one of the
functions U and the other one V okay
let's have a look so what V in this case
that's X and then the next thing along
is you - there's you right there you
already know what you - is though if u
is five what's you - what happens when
you differentiate it it's zero that's
what you told me over here all right so
it's x times zero plus all right now
comes the second half what's you it's
look carefully it's just the number five
right and then what's V - yeah it's the
derivative of X which we already
established is one so you're like oh
it's zero plus five which as we
established before is five that's the
actual result we have now for cases like
this could be like why would you go
through such a long rule to do this well
in cases like this you would not go
through such a long rule you just use
this quicker rule that you already know
but we're gonna start to get to more
complicated things like for example
mmm I shouldn't rub that off because
that was a perfect example but anyway if
I ask you to differentiate something
like this x squared plus 1 to the 7 and
then 5 x squared minus X have a look at
this guy right now even though this
looks long and gross number one what
will we do for this first part here we
have a Rufus we don't need to expand it
what we use it's written up above on the
board use the chain on this right you do
the outside seven this to the six and
then you do the inside what's the inside
2x just there right so that's the chain
rule part but then when you do this your
are gross I'm gonna multiply out by this
whole thing
no you don't you would call this U and
you'd call this V and then you'd go
through V u let's just quickly do it
it's equal to here's V u - can we can we
do this guy 7 x squared plus 1 what
happens to the 70 good there's the
outside code you the inside now 2 X
there's the V u - what's next
have a look at my role just you right
here's you right here x squared plus 1
to the 7 multiplied by V - so here's V
so what's V - can you read off what V -
should be 10x comes from here and then
minus 1 so you guys are really getting
the hang of it now I know this looks
awful and gross but guess what you did
the whole thing that's it no expansion
necessary and in fact this form here is
already sort of in in the right sort of
set up to do the next thing that you'll
learn about a bit later on so even
though it looks terrible
that's actually exactly where you want
it to be okay